the
biggest ridiculous question especially
to ask an economist but also a human
being
what's the meaning of life i hope you've
gotten the answer that from somebody
i think we're all still working on that
one but um what is it you know
i actually learned a lot from my son uh
luke and uh he's
he's 19 now but but he's always loved
philosophy and he reads way more
sophisticated philosophy than i do we i
once took him to oxford he spent the
whole time like pulling all these
obscure books down and reading them
and a couple years ago we had this
argument
um and he was trying to convince me that
hedonism was the
ultimate you know meaning of life just
pleasure
yeah seeking and how old was he at the
time
but he made a really good like
intellectual argument for it too and you
know
of course it just didn't strike me as
right and and i think that
um you know while i am kind of
utilitarian like you know i do think we
should do the grace good for the grace
number
that's just too shallow and i think i've
convinced myself
that um real happiness doesn't come from
seeking pleasure it's kind of a little
it's ironic like if you really focus on
being happy i think it
it doesn't work you gotta like be doing
something bigger it's
i think the analogy i sometimes use is
um you know when you look at a dim star
in the sky if you look right at it it
kind of disappears but you have to look
a little to the side
and then the parts of your your retina
that are better at absorbing
light you know can pick it up better
it's the same thing with happiness i
think
you need to sort of find something other
goal something some meaning in life and
that ultimately makes you
happier than if you go squarely at just
pleasure
and so for me you know the kind of
research i do
that i think is trying to change the
world make the world a better place
and i'm not like an evolutionary
psychologist but my guess is that our
brains are wired
not just for pleasure but we're social
animals and we're wired to like
help others and ultimately you know
that's something that's really
deeply rooted in our psyche and if we do
help others if we do
or at least feel like we're helping
others you know our reward systems kick
in and we end up being more
deeply satisfied than if we just do
something selfish and shallow
beautifully put i don't think there's a
better way to end it eric
you're one of the people when i first
showed up at mit
that made me proud to be at mit so it's
so sad that you're now at stanford but
as
i'm sure you'll do wonderful things at
stanford as well i
i can't wait till future books and
people should definitely read
well thank you so much and i think we're
all we're all part of the invisible
college as we call it you know we're all
part of this intellectual and human
community where we all can learn from
each other it doesn't really matter
physically where we are so much anymore
beautiful thanks for talking today
my pleasure
you